nyc the big apple new york city ever
heard of it gang the boys are gonna be
here gotham comedy club november 9th on
the isle of manhattan we're coming back
we're storming the beaches get some
tickets and come see us it's the new
york comedy festival our first time in
it you don't want to miss it the show's
going to sell out also the boys are
going to be in hartford connecticut on
december 14th and we're going to go to
albany new york on december 15th and
then where are we going after that big
man we're gonna be in syracuse december
16th get those tickets
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage
the show where you find out if your
favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r u garbage here it is it's a little
show we sit down with your favorite
communities
they grow up to be classy yeah they're
just a big old piece of trash
we got two of them right here in the
studio i'm your host stage foley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're down
here at aunt toddy's basement yeah she's
feeling fine she's feeling good sure i
saw her reading a book upstairs really
it was a hustler
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table
that was a good one like they had a
couple zingers in before payday you know
what i mean he's the ceo of ru garbage
international businessman
known in many circles yeah are you going
to g2 what's the deal or g12
you going to that i'm more of a g-18
[Laughter]
on the standby list couple of g strings
if i could if i may think those guys
party over there i would be i party here
it's probably a big old [ __ ] fest over
there it's like the olympics
those dudes get after it
give it up for kevin james ryan god damn
we got kj in the building let's go
let's go hey gang happy to be here as
always please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube and as
you know those numbers are true through
the [ __ ] roof shout out to youtube
youtube's pretty good we got a shout out
to big kev for that uh yeah yeah big cav
shout out for youtube um what are you
you watching out over there on the
youtube
uh over there on street radio dude uh
and then
hmm let me find my notes we had a
production patreon.com don't be stupid
what are you doing
what does the yams are watching
again over there on that patreon yeah
it's cooking go check it out we're
almost i don't like to to my own horn i
want to get us over the edge we're
almost at twenty thousand dollars over
there on that feature yeah that's pretty
good that's pretty [ __ ] bonkers seven
million hours of bonus content you get a
lot of [ __ ] i'll come clean your car if
you need me too we got videos we got
bonus episode we got hard feelings yeah
uh i love it we got a lot of [ __ ] on
there check it out i have cheesesteak
egg rolls
pound for pound might be the best one
best patreon out there comedy podcast
i'm going toe-to-toe i'm throwing it
down except them dylan andrew schultz
and a couple others
nine other millionaires
but we're having fun over there so check
it out yeah we love it and i have a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good we're all going to be
going to the mensinger show yeah soon i
think this is already out but maybe sure
it already happened
way to launch it i did not take
mushrooms give it up for t-bone mcmuffin
toby mcmullen what's up dudes what up
t-bone dude uh so i was editing the last
family episode and in foley's intro he
alludes to [ __ ] aunt today really you
said you had a spicy relationship which
means now in our world in the canon of
are you garbage fully banged on 2d
unless we reboot this thing and do a lot
of retcon change the backstory hey
wookiopedia take it easy will you what
wikipedia star wars reference that's
where they have all the information
about the canon of star wars
toby got it he knows exactly what i'm
talking about probably his home page
um
and yeah it's not all fleshed out you
know what i mean we're still in season
one here
also too
who knows she's even a real aunt
she could just be a family friend she's
not our aunt we live with aunt hoodie
but she's not our aunt we i've
established that really sex with her yes
i've seen a couple of videos over on the
hub where ants and nephews get going the
one time they were stuck in a hotel room
and with only one bed you do you really
like that no i don't no that was like
the biggest video i would typically this
is not an a what is a family program but
that was like the biggest video in
pornhub in like a year all right it was
like it did like 375 million views what
are you what are you talking about what
are you typing in i don't type in
anything i stay around that suggested
for you really you let the algorithm do
the work they got my number i'll tell
you that
porn mr hubs got me dead the rights
he knows what he's doing talking about
an sco
gang this is a family episode i don't
think it is with the [ __ ] what we're
talking about over here
gang it's a family episode we're going
to be reading off your questions as you
know when you sign up for the old
patreon there we'll uh we'll answer
we'll ask your questions on the air now
we got a bit of a bit of a backlog as kj
says but we promise we're going to get
to the mall yeah of course uh and also
like we said
you get for if you're on patreon you get
first crack at a garbage question it's
just the best way to do it everybody i
mean we get the dms we get the emails
people [ __ ] knock on my door hey do
you ever think i thought about it we've
got to get to the patreon yes we get a
hot one right dm yeah sure then i pass
that off as mine no big deal
you've you've you've done that a couple
no i always give credit where credit is
due yeah right
[Laughter]
oh yeah we're working on that something
like that yeah yeah i already got one on
my list well that's my go-to answer
anyway for legal if anybody brings up
anything to me yeah it's like snl you
guys somebody sign away all right
somebody cause somebody can ask me about
like oh yeah they're putting up a cvs so
i had any idea
i was in the movie doing that sure sure
but now of course we always make sure
everybody knows who
pops out yeah of course we're having fun
over here we're having a good time yeah
t-bone's fiddling with the cam
t-bone you all right over there you're
freaking me out take the lens cap off
what's happening buttons get on it did
you ever have a uh what like a an older
family member that like would like tell
you to sit down because they're you're
making them nervous when they when you
stand around them no i don't think i had
a couple of uncles that if they were
sitting down you couldn't like stand
over them oh like yeah you're making you
sit down you're making me nervous i
would get that uh yeah but you're
breathing heavy i know
they think you're gonna snatch the
[ __ ] turkey leg out of them
you're like a seagull they think you're
gonna swoop in and grab something
and take out a knife floating over the
breakfast you just spit and it's in your
beard okay i've been doing that now it's
on your hand i saw you wipe your nose on
your hand then on your shirt i've been
doing that a lot
man
this guy is boogers
[Applause]
really man
me being such a germaphobe the fact it's
like god's sick thing the fact that i'm
such a germaphobe
and now i'm connected to life with a
germ it's a tough look i'm starting to
get to the point where this is like this
is like immersion therapy you know what
i mean like if you're afraid of heights
they throw you out of a plane they do
that
i'm afraid of germs so i have to have a
podcast with you
um i'm getting to the well now we're
turning the corner we got the meal plan
coming all right all that stuff this has
been a big corner you've been trying to
turn for two years
i'm gearing up i'm priming the pumps i
need cake
[Laughter]
guys fat quartz on patreon it's a
[ __ ] doozy okay anyway i noticed
yesterday when we were having we were
having a nice meal just fat court with a
good friend of ours no i'm just gonna
say okay i'm aware that i might be
repulsing people with my eating with the
way i eat well thanks for tuning in yeah
yeah i do the napkin i have to be very
careful i like you know sometimes i'll
hold the napkin with a bite
it's very geriatric the way i eat it is
but there's also a speed to it that like
wait it's quick or it's slow it's quick
you i think
this is more patreon content we'll give
them a little sneak peek
i think you
you're aware of how fast you're eating
so you slow it down in mixed company yes
because i've done this i'm aware because
i'm just about to but i assume there's
food on my face
and i feel like i'm grossing out the
other people that's why
i wouldn't say grossing out but i would
say
you don't make a lot of eye contact with
me no i treat it like a bank job dude
no [ __ ] witnesses head down no eye
contact drop the gun walk out quick but
not fast yeah um
i was the mutual friend that we had we
had a meal with yesterday had dinner
with uh-huh he had at one point had
suggested i because there was sun-dried
tomatoes in my dish sure and he said oh
you like you like sun-dried tomatoes i
said yeah there's just a lot of them so
i'm pushing them side a little bit and i
got the feeling
that he i said if you want one please
help yourself
i don't think that was ever on the table
in my head i'm like man does he not know
what a what a slime ball i am he's going
to share food with me
cause you wouldn't what no
there's no way you would take a like if
i took a bite of a hamburger you would
take a bite a bite of it no because
that's bad
right the two ways okay i want a little
look in the kippy's head here
this is what a psycho takes his real
patreon content
as you hold the burger you bite into it
that half that you bit into is now a
no-fly zone in my book okay
say antarctica yeah that's like the
[ __ ] 87th parallel
can't cross it was that the right number
something like that yeah i figured you
would know that johnny army 82nd
maybe no it's 87th or 89th whatever
um
buttons get a google on that will you
uh i i don't even know what you're
talking about talking about type in 87th
parallel i think it's that yeah it's the
korean peninsula i believe yourself
vietnam no
korea i think it's korea
wow we look like a couple of [ __ ]
commies over here
hey big red relax
yeah a circle of latitude in north in
the north in the northern hemisphere in
the arctic ocean is what 87th yep oh so
i pulled it right
no you didn't i said 87th parallel is
that the one that divides north korea
and south korea though oh gee god
we couldn't just let kimi win it and
move on never
met me
i thought i thought i got out clean i
know it exists i'm trying to deflect
from my slob eating
so that's north korea right right that's
done i can't go and i would assume where
the hands make contact with the hands
are dirtier than the mouth i presume
from what i've seen on a day-to-day
basis over the past decade it's so the
hands aren't good
like a komodo dragon
yeah if i get that on me and then it's
like stuck to your [ __ ] you know it's
like shoots the gak at ya
uh but i don't i wouldn't that's with
most people so you you're you know
the lady the lady you'll share right
you'll
of course
what about you toby would you eat off my
plate
i have yes he has
what have you eaten please it looks like
a [ __ ] wet rat right now i believe
i've used my fork in your plate as well
yeah yeah we're sharing yeah good luck
with the herpes yeah oh man don't remind
me oh no at that juncture i stayed far
the [ __ ] away yeah when i had a screamer
down in houston
there's grass on the field
yeah that was a i caught a burner going
in there we talked about it and you used
my napkin and then i used it and i've
been thinking about it every day since
and i'm a scruncher
i like a lot of napkins oh man
oh that's good that's good stuff that's
good stuff right there but the one thing
that you mentioned that it was it was
real trashy like you know one of those
like uh blue-collar colloquialisms that
i'm always you know you say i'm always
good for i always got in the hopper
catholic school colloquialism no like
sane you know what i mean like you know
you can't catch the train if you ride
the bus or whatever um
was my grandfather or anybody the older
people would say what oh okay i thought
you got old people and eating bugs yeah
dude i can't even be in the same [ __ ]
yeah that's a tough one one time we went
to visit my grandmother when i was a kid
real quick at a nursing home and uh we
were in the cafeteria and this old guy
that she was friends was eating
scrambled eggs nope and something
happened that's going to ruin my day
just here and then something happened
and he started shooting uh scrambled
eggs out of his nose i've been there uh
i was on they go up quick
there's like no gravity with those
things they they operate on their own i
was over easy for the next 10 years
burn them yeah oh my god i remember just
being like
i look at vanilla pudding in my hand too
experience
god bless the old people but you know it
can be a tough look all right so go
ahead your grandfather if there was a
game on and you were a kid right like
say [ __ ] thanksgiving and there's
like the football game on sure whatever
and there's like bunch of kids running
around or you're standing your wall
whatever you get hit with you'll make a
way better door than you do windows oh
yeah you make a way better daughter hey
who's winning the game i can tell you if
i can see it with these damn kids
running around hey pop up upgrade the
material well yeah come over here and
slap your arm i'll throw you in please
[Laughter]
shout out to pop big pop
is he pop the big the patriot pop and
then the yes my dad's popped too his his
dad was pop now he's popping oh you
don't say yeah and my mom's grandma
or gamma
and they were babies all right stop it
i'll knock it off between that and the
scrambled eggs i'm not going to sleep at
night
i need a chlorine shower oh man
with that being said let's get into some
questions that's what i was going to say
no that's what i was let's do this is a
silly one having a good time having a
good old time um
let's see this one's from jennifer this
was a big one when i was a kid
oh no sorry this is a different one um
this is from jennifer have you ever
fallen out of a car as a kid because
there was no seat belt that was a thing
that happened with older cars the doors
would just open
remember that that's when they put in
that child safety [ __ ] yeah you would
make a left turn and the kids there
would be that bench seat and it would
just [ __ ] shoot right out into the
[ __ ] intersection like the mailman
uh i've almost fallen out yeah and i've
gotten screamed at for it too but i was
messing with the door that that those
that's when they came out i remember
they came out with the child locks i
remember looking at my mom like yo if
you engage these things i'm gonna be
real [ __ ] pissed we trust each other
here what am i in a [ __ ] squad car i
know what the [ __ ] lady yeah it's like
you got me on a b and e you're bringing
me downtown
i don't like that at least crack a
window you know what else i don't like
what i hate the child window in the back
yeah i got to get my elbow out sure they
should be able to engage that
disengagement what all the way down yeah
that's tough [ __ ] out of here with that
yeah yeah yeah man um it's brutal when
you're back there you feel like an idiot
i don't like on my windows i think you
feel like an idiot most times but that's
just me i don't like when my windows
half down i feel like if i get into an
accident that's it that's gonna hurt you
even more it's gonna slice your face off
i like it all the way up or all the way
down no in between
i mean you're cuckoo bananas doesn't
that make sense though what is the
difference between all the way up and
halfway down well i'm stuck in a face
full of glass yeah it's breaking it's
not gonna [ __ ] it's not going to come
out at one piece and [ __ ] denogenize
you like fifth dimension
put them in the denominator
oh it's from seinfeld
yes
he was coming over coming up with names
for the lopper
yeah he'll get you the son of dad that
was mine
yeah i i just feel like
it could hit you sure i guess cut my
jugular yeah it's over uh i don't know
if i've ever mentioned this but pulling
into uh wildwood new jersey where i
freak frequented it as a child there was
a wooden bridge trying to throw you over
it
there was a wooden bridge
and it was like there was pieces it look
i would love to see it now as an adult
to see how structurally sound it was but
as a [ __ ] six-year-old kid and then
my dad would tease me because he's a
real nice guy you know
this gives his kid a little anxiety
before his week off yeah it would be
[ __ ] nighttime we'd be pulling in on
a friday and we'd be like dad let us
know when we're getting to the bridge
we'd be like panicked this thing's going
to collapse
and he'd be like roll the windows down
in case it collapses we can swim out
that's what he would tell us
yeah
well dude like a [ __ ] six-year-old a
seven-year-old but that's true you have
to i know but it was an accident you
might not be able to get the window down
with the pressure that's dude i learned
that at five years old
on my way to the [ __ ] ferris wheel i
was [ __ ]
in here i wonder if i was a fat little
kid i was eating my feelings
two more slices of sam's please this
might be my last meal i think i've told
you my dad taught me something like that
when i was really young too young um
when he would turn all the lights off in
the house and turn the lights on outside
and we would just sit and look out the
window yeah and he said when the lights
are out when it when they can see it
yeah when you can't see it when the
lights are out there they can't see you
it's kind of like some knowledge some
knob [ __ ] that's got 87 parallel written
all over it he hadn't set up claymores
in the trees
a couple of tripwires out front that was
right around the same time we switched
him over to decaf um
[Laughter]
dad's digging bungee stick bits
no more diet coke in the 18 for you
trying to get my tv dinner on
[Laughter]
but how how scary would it be what
because
that water thing is the kind of thing
where you have to wait till it fills up
it has to fill up completely before you
can swim out yeah plus you're for sure
going to drown because you're going to
open the door and be like ah jesus and
then suck in a bunch of water yeah also
unless you're in a convertible you're
[ __ ]
i mean let's call a spade a spade here i
never like to i never like a coop
getting in the back seat pulling the
seat back and getting back there i kind
of was a death trap yeah oh that was my
worst fear yeah
having a kick out that back window to
get out
that's great i mean yeah i mean your
anxiety runs at another level
it's cooking talking about true to roof
it ain't no patreon i'll tell you that
um
this is in the same realm this is from
michelle this is my first question did
you ever have to duck down on a pickup
truck because you didn't have enough
seat belts for everyone
that was a big or even any car yeah back
in the day you would lap it like if you
were coming home from soccer practice
say like say my dad was taking home like
the friend's kid hey well you know we'll
all go here or whatever we'll take them
back to my house there might be like
seven eight nine kids in a [ __ ] jeep
sure lapped up and then there would be
like oh there's a cop [ __ ] hit the
deck yeah make sure no you don't get
[ __ ] wrapped up we used to lay down
in the back of a truck back of a pickup
we did that you know when it became uh
frowned upon to do that yeah some areas
you can hawaii they're big on that
they're always in the back of the trucks
i told you i did it in the dominican
republic probably nice cruising around
real nice tropical air anti-aircraft gun
hanging out
i'm manning the big guy taking out migs
left and right um
but i think i might have said this as a
kid i had my dad we had like my dad had
a work truck and it was on the weekend
we were doing something and me and my
two buddies i was like yeah we'll
[ __ ] ride in the back of it like he
was like running errands and we were
just [ __ ] cruising around in the back
of it and then the kid went home and
told his mom hey i was riding in the
back of a pickup truck and he was in the
lot he was never allowed back over my
house really yeah which i get do you
think the mom called your parents uh i
think that happened yeah
yeah
also yeah his mom was a little bit of a
stickler for the rules yeah my dad tend
to look the other way on a lot of things
broad was uptight yeah i don't want to
say he might he might be a listener he
still likes some posts from time to time
but i get it i mean now if i was a kid i
wouldn't want my kid in the back of a
pickup truck wouldn't do any of that
[ __ ] what do you mean they were smoking
we turned out pretty well though
what well one of us falling apart over
here yeah um that the charred meat the
[ __ ] whole nine yards yeah i like it
crispy
dog good night let's talk about the
daily tip my friend presented by bet mgm
that's right talking about the big dogs
there if you're new to bedding if you're
a seasoned veteran however you like to
do your uh you're betting when you're
betting on sports it's best to be in the
know uh-huh if you listen to the daily
tip you will be yeah they got uh the
best betting analysis and information
and it's a pretty good show too right
they got a good factor good riffing the
hosts are great the host michael jackson
michael jenkins and chelsea messenger
break down the big takeaways and make
sure you know everything you need to bet
smarter uh with featured guests like
bookmakers audacity insiders and bet mgm
experts you've always got a fresh take
on the action as you know if you're a
bet and i used to i started betting in
college high schools you know but you
know just kids got the fever things are
always changing and you just need info
right you need up-to-date info what's
happening you need to take it back this
kicker that trade here trade there you
just need info information is power when
it comes to this kind of stuff that's
right so as much as fun as it is to bet
on the game it's even more fun when
you've got the inside scoop there you go
ready to bet with an edge tune into the
daily tip right presented by bet mgm
listen weekdays 6 a.m to 9 00 a.m
eastern on audacity spotify or your
favorite podcast app one more time guys
the daily tip presented by bet mgm
listen weekdays 6 a.m to 9 00 a.m
eastern on audacity spotify and your
favorite podcast app do it yeah kippy
how about that all form all form got a
brand new couch sitting in the studio
it's unbelievable folks over there helix
got into the couch game yeah i love
their mattresses now they're doing the
couches t-bone's taking a little snooze
on her right now i'm looking at him it's
fantastic drifting off into dreamland
all right uh they were cool enough to
send us one uh we needed a new couch for
for toddy's anyway we did perfect and i
got it is it hard to set up i did it all
by myself and i'm not even messing
around less than an hour 25 minutes or
something crazy it all pieces together
it's like you know it's like a model
it's like boom boom boom boom you screw
it in real quick it's not a two-man job
one guy can do it i did it and i'm a
bozo as you know
uh i will back him up on that he is a
bozo what makes it really cool is for
starters it's the easiest way you can
customize the sofa using premium
materials at a fraction of the cost of
traditional storage you go on you pick
the color you want the shape you want
the size you want the legs you want the
whole nine yards they do it uh also if
it's delivered directly to your home
with a fast free shipping uh right now
if you buy a sofa from a traditional
retailer it'll take months to arrive i
just jammed my sister up she went to get
a new couch they were turning like 18
months oh yeah that's ridiculous yeah my
mom got caught up in the same thing yeah
that thing was here and like like
it felt like two hours i know it was
like i hit enter and then the guy was
knocking on the door it really was it
really did come quick uh yeah so if
getting to sofas uh trying it in store
sounds a little too risky you don't need
to worry you get 100 days to decide if
you want to keep it or not you know
these these companies are top-notch um
and if you don't love it they'll pick it
up for free and give you a full refund
nice um
let's see uh to find the perfect silver
for you check out allform.com garbage
and all forms this is this is the thing
baby all form is offering 20
off all orders for our listeners at
allforum.com garbage one more time 20
off your order for our listeners at all
form.com garbage do it yeah um this is a
very [ __ ] car episode this one's from
chris scott ever use a leaf blower to
clean out your car [ __ ] hey really oh
it's the best what they do it at the
uh at the car wash a blo oh they blow
out
dude it's awesome and my brother has a
pretty sick blower he's got like a still
i bet he does
like a still you know the stills sti
steel steel yeah he's got one of those
things hums you couldn't put that
together that it's steel yeah
this is a great company it's real strong
it's called still
anyway yeah when i when that thing's in
the garage and i go home
blast it all out really oh never thought
of that it's great you just got to open
the doors on the other side and blow it
out
take the rugs out through the rugs
[ __ ] noise you know what i associate
steel with one of the greatest programs
of all times the great outdoor games the
where the lumberjacks compete oh yeah
you've seen that you catch that on espn2
on like a friday afternoon or something
down and up with the sausages
yeah i thought i'd be pretty good at
that yeah yeah you know thought about it
i've never worked a chainsaw i don't
know how to get three people at those
things but they're packed
what i don't know how they get three
people yeah i mean it's like 5 000
people watching guys [ __ ] cut down a
tree think about the rural aspects of
the [ __ ] i would go watch it for sure
really yeah a couple of beers let's do
it somebody line us up with some ticks
you remember well you know what all the
other in that same world what other show
was really good that lager show extreme
loggers or alaskan loggers or whatever
where they would [ __ ] hook them up
and [ __ ]
drag them up the hill
oh yeah those guys would get maimed
that's always nice
did you talk about it
that'll [ __ ] lop you right off
[Laughter]
friday at seven welcome back to maine
getting maimed
oh that was a scary concept when you
were a kid you'll get maimed yeah that
was screamed at me a couple of times
that dramatic fever my mom would throw
at me
i think it was rheumatic
you'll get real catch rheumatic fever
how old are you that's what i was saying
about a better chance of getting scavies
third grade with tb
i got popping up manic fever rheumatic
or it's not can't be pneumatic i'm
having trouble remembering it i think
it's rheumatic fever oh she worked in a
hospital she was in the medical field oh
yeah janitor but still it's it's
rheumatic fever it's a disease that can
result from inadequately treated strep
throat reasonable i would have strep
throat all the time scarlet fever yeah i
don't know what that is
that means you're a [ __ ]
then mark me with an s shout out to the
scarlet letter um
wait
two things i never understood hit me
well more than that but for these
purposes
for our purposes here today one of them
being euros
now i got that all figured out um
pneumonia and walking pneumonia
yeah what's that all about i think
walking pneumonia means you can walk
around
you're okay
uh
t-bones on it
because pneumonia is fluid in your lungs
is it yeah that's all it is it's fluid
and not all it is but it's fluid in your
lungs and i guess walking ammonia is
probably an abbreviated version of that
it's just milder symptoms of pneumonias
okay walking pneumonia sounds worse
to me like it's walking all over you
that's how you take it honestly yeah
that sounds like that he's beating the
[ __ ] out of him
yeah walking the muzzle walking and
walking all over me yeah no yeah walking
pneumonia is uh yeah less severe
fever that's what she would cause i
would get strep throat every year why my
tonsils you're smoking yeah smoking
bernie's at seven
uh
my tonsils were back had me switch over
to lights for a couple of months
hey i know you're not it's not as cool
but hit the ultra lights for the summer
will you
uh yeah i would get no i would every i
would get it the same week every year it
would be like
[ __ ] the after february like the
first week of march strep wasn't that
bad once you got over the initial panic
of seeing those white things in the
backyard you got swallowing for two days
where you couldn't even like ice pops
yeah but it's not that was that was my
ticket to unlimited iceberg you would
wake up at like three in the morning
your mouth be all dry like two talk
about wanting to be denogenized i would
have taken if they would have been like
we'll cut your [ __ ] drake out i would
do it really and you're in so much pain
every swallow was like a [ __ ] you had
to think about and then yeah i could do
it i could do a little strep throat
you're what yeah a little ginger ale on
the couch you can have that i mean you
probably do that most days anyway yeah
but it's better when you're a little kid
and you're sick and your mom does all
that [ __ ] for you
she runs to the store i could get some
ice pops that and was big was on the
paper if you were if you were out of
school like if i was like hey you're
gonna stay home right my mom would
whatever
get me situated on the couch
then go run and get two movies
head up there to blockbuster or epic
videos let's grab some wings
hit that back room too see if there's
any ants and uncles going at it when you
guys were kids in sick did you have like
uh a standard set of movies you like to
watch on sick days
uh i mean price was right was always a
[ __ ] yeah he had to do the prices
right i was a big kelly rip a guy so i
would do regis and kelly big fan of
kelly
you've been watching daytime tv roseau
yeah rosie o'donnell shows what the
broads are yapping about on the view you
know uh regis regis is a born
entertainer and that she was eye candy i
was more of a regent kathy lee man
you're an older guy that's right that's
when it was done right yeah gelman ran
the show gelman still ran the show
probably still does
um
rosie o'donnell show had a nice program
at 10 o'clock i believe it was she did
yeah that was it yeah i was more tv
there was no offer of movies my mom
would go every now and if she wasn't if
she was i guess at that point she was
working nights or like through like you
know second shift or whatever so she
would go get you know i'd be like hey
get whatever and whatever or something
like two cars sometimes you get
something like [ __ ] adam sandler or
[ __ ] you know david spade or
something i could squeeze some ice pops
out of patty and i could squeeze some
cran apple or crane grape out of her
that was usually about as far as it went
why what would you watch teenage mutant
ninja turtles 2 secret of the use oh
that of course anything i had on deck
was big oh the vhs i'm talking yeah you
only had like yeah but like we probably
we never had that collection we had like
a handful of things that like
we you know we never returned to
blockbuster oh dude i've seen ferris
bueller's day off about 97 times
wait you had actual like movies like
that we didn't really have movies like
unless unless we taped it no that we
never did that oh yeah we were big for
[ __ ] you don't work there
work for nasa to understand that they're
right there no i know you jerked off to
the one seven thousand times police
academy yeah hear that patty while you
were out there hard working this guy's
at home tugging his little route
[Laughter]
yeah those movies right there we've had
those since 19
i don't know [ __ ] 85 whenever we got
our first vcr yeah that was that's
i get it but yeah no we at least had a
handful of movies that you got in
something well my mom did is she signed
up for hbo for like a month taped a
bunch of [ __ ]
and then and then canceled it yeah
they're all they're all original hbo uh
tapings every single
vhs like that growing up would open with
the hbo [ __ ]
going to get going down the street yeah
the old one [ __ ] sweet that's so
trashy
that's [ __ ] interesting that's a
tight title card though i'll tell you
that
wow your mom was a bootlegger
that's crazy your mom was bootlegging
films
moving a couple down at the hair salon
huh holy [ __ ] she's leaning in i got la
elia
you seen tommy boy
holy [ __ ] dude yeah slimy talk about
slanging them out the trunk that in the
world
was doing it that that in the last
episode of mash went around my family
she had that taped we wore that thing
out she was a big alan alda fan a little
too big
someone said you're a little too big
uh wow yeah that's crazy no i never did
that we just had a handful of them
yeah unnecessary roughness was a big one
remember that i was 10 years i was in
college when i came out okay
i'm asking if you remembered i didn't
ask [ __ ] how old you were i remember
the film okay is that with keanu no that
was the replacement unnecessary
roughness was with the was the
quarterback it was the old guy he had
two years of eligibility so he went back
and played
t-bone you're on that buttons has it
bert lancaster
of what i mean he wasn't he hold this
[ __ ] scott bakula got back what yeah no
way yeah
yeah and uh shut up and sinbad yeah this
movie's got it all sinbad was the coach
i think
uh and then it was a female kicker and
she was a type that was the replacement
you bozo
which one's joey cocodiaz in the
replacement no that's longest yard you
stink what are you even here if you're
combining
who was the coach al pacino you're just
combining every football movie from the
last one you charge a blitch you run
from a
you run from a pass
you charge a rush you run from a pass
what do you think uh necessary roughness
rating on rotten tomatoes in my house it
was about a ten thousand yeah [ __ ]
rotten tomatoes what is that [ __ ]
33. that's pretty good they don't
[ __ ] know what they're talking about
well what's the fan rating or is that
46. favorite come on fifty percent
pretty good that's a coin flip not bad
yeah that was a good piece of business
piece of [ __ ] or modern glasses
yeah i mean come on what were you doing
here
let's see i don't jive with rotten
tomatoes anymore they weren't corporate
didn't they
[ __ ] them who scooped them up
i don't work for that t-mobile post or
somebody probably one of the posts but
it's also like everything that gets like
the [ __ ] listen this is a very a [ __ ]
a critic a movie i don't get that oh
warner brothers bought it oh
if you guys are in the market for a
podcast what a boom in patreon
i'm [ __ ] jamie on the spot over here
today with the google pretty good
um
all right this one's [ __ ] home run
for miguel del torre ever take your
shirt off before a fight
[Laughter]
you were guaranteed to get your ass
kicked man that kid always got that was
always a and done okay that kid went
down like a bag of dirt
[Laughter]
oh that's something with pulling up your
pants
[Laughter]
talk about a [ __ ] uh i see
oh man that's [ __ ] great
holy [ __ ] that's always the sign of a
guy who's like let me let me try to
scare him now listen if my shirt came
off in the middle dude if somebody even
like you know my i would tuck my shirt
in to make sure it wasn't coming that
was a tough look too when they rip your
shirt yeah
titties are flopping around it's like
spring break
it's like it's like kippy's going wild
over there yeah i i didn't i didn't have
the uh i didn't have the rip shirt body
that wasn't really fabio
i'd wear a jumpsuit if it was a
scheduled fight but i remember two girls
got into a fight i was a freshman and
two girls
both pretty hot got into a fight they
were like a junior and senior got into a
fight in the hallway
and both of their shirts got ripped off
and it was literally just two bras going
at it
goddamn that'll change a 16 year old's
life
yeah man
i got that that on loop for a little
while yeah yeah yeah that was always
playing in the background if you know
what i mean
like a baseball game holy [ __ ] yikes
spicy um
first time i ever saw a lace bra
i don't even know what that is i'm not
sure what lace is i gotta be honest with
you
i'm gonna go listen we're all friends
here
i'm gonna shoot you straight
the old lady keeps it traditional
what's lace like the
lace you know the little yeah describe
to define it with the word that i don't
understand i think i know but i've i've
never been like ooh all right let's see
if i can let's see if i can i know what
i could if you showed me a bra and a
lace bra be able to pick it up it's
ready i'll see if i can define it you
pull it up
sure you have it up are you were you
looking for a definition yeah yeah i
know what laces okay hold on all right
i'll tell you okay give me one second
it's delicate
okay soft
it has little holes in it so you can
kind of see a little nippy
and has like flowers on it
you've i don't think you got one word
right out of the proper definition i'm
not even [ __ ] around
a fine open fabric typically with one
cotton or silk made by looping twisting
or knitting thread and pattern
specifically used for trimming garments
oh man i'm taking a look at these bad
boys my lady's got a couple
and they ain't too shavy
[Laughter]
keeping kids hard
[Laughter]
kip let's talk about that box of awesome
bespoke post bespoke post you got me
right there and they tell you something
they are awesome yeah all right the
falls here
okay if you like cool stuff get yourself
a box of awesome from bespoke post it
could be grooming materials it could be
outdoor barbecue stuff it could just be
outdoor stuff pocket knives hammocks
it's all those two clothes too you keep
telling me that i forget keep forgetting
that doing clothes as well uh-huh and
coolest part about them is they partner
with small businesses emerging brands
they bring you the most unique goods
every month that's what i like yeah it's
like you know it's it's boutique yeah
it's boutique it's well made handcrafted
guy [ __ ] cool guy [ __ ] it's good to get
started take the quiz at box of
awesome.com your answers are gonna help
them pick the right box of awesome for
you as we've always said new boxes come
out every month tons of different
categories whatever you're into you can
find something you want travel gear
whatever you want it's free to sign up
you can skip a month at any time if you
want one one month we got to take a
month off do it again in two months easy
peasy sure each box only costs 45 bucks
and has a total of 70 worth of gear in
it free money baby a lot of money nice
uh plus with each box of awesome like we
said you're supporting small business
ninety percent of everything that comes
in your box of awesome is from a small
up-and-coming brand here's the deal you
get 20 off your first monthly box when
you sign up for box of awesome.com and
enter the promo code garbage at checkout
that's box of awesome dot com code
garbage for twenty percent off your
first box do it
ooh let's talk about mint mobile real
man mobile yeah
mobile the guys who are turning it
upside down by passing the savings on to
you
because what happens when you sign up
for a big contract mobile number mobile
phone you all jammed up fees overages
contracts and this and that next thing
you know they got you over a barrel mint
mobile goes right to you they pass the
savings on to you now i've been told i
don't know if it's true it can't be true
i earn 15 a month 15 bucks a month
that's bunker bonkos you get unlimited
talk tax high speed data delivered on
the nation's largest 5g network that's
mint mobile baby it's the same thing
you're getting the other big guys are
offering you're getting it for 15 bucks
15 clams a month i've always said this
my wife uses it been using it for years
that's a pack of bernies
you ain't lying you ain't lying uh my
wife uses it and it she never signed a
contract she used this temporarily and
now it's the go-to thing
you never need anything else so if your
contract's up you're looking at a second
line whatever you're doing if you're in
the market for a new cell phone plan
check out mint mobile have you covered
seven day money back guarantee uh to get
your new wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month and get the plan shifted to your
door for free go to mintmobile.com
garbage that's mintmobile.com garbage
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at midmobile.com
when was your last official childhood
fight do you remember
what's childhood just we'll keep it
strict i'm not talking about college or
after college ah that's when they got
that's when they got up something got a
little dangerous yeah uh child
i fought a kid the other day
yeah i thought i fought a nine year old
really
jerry neraski keep his [ __ ] mouth
shut i've been beefing with some
kickball kids we would
we were a little [ __ ] wonky as in we
would fight each other most times
most scuffles were friends me and my
brother fought every like physically
fist fought every single day one summer
yeah every day yeah it was insane yeah
that was i mean me and my boys would get
drunk and then somebody would say
something whatever and then you would
[ __ ] end up in a tussle like a it was
probably junior high before and then
college and
early 20s
a good amount drinking in five my last
child like high school there was a few
fights
but my last childhood like childhood
childhood fight was in seventh grade
uh this kid i think dan brown or dave
brown beat the
[ __ ] out of me yeah and i deserved it
100 uh-huh oh i no i'm sure you did it
was one of those old-school ones where
he was like a good guy i was running my
mouth or something like that and i
thought i could take him and i went in
real quick and next thing i know he's on
top of me he's like half the size of me
he's on top and he had a cast on his
right hand because he had broken i got
hit by a cast dude he was just [ __ ]
wailing on you yeah i thought my face
was gonna fall off uh-huh and he hit me
like four or five times and stopped and
he's like are you done and i was like
yeah yeah and then he put out his hand
and he and he helped me up and we were
buddy we were buddies from there on out
yeah i mean you were his [ __ ]
i had to pull my pockets
yeah all right hey bunny ears let's go
put a little kool-aid powder on my lips
like your skirt up put some lace on i
wanted to ask you this too this i'm here
for it big guys because it happened to
me yesterday uh-huh have you ever been
putting on your underwear and both legs
go in one hole but yeah but you still
pull them up just uh whatever i don't
think i got them all the way up no yeah
i feel sexy
[Laughter]
wait you just yanked him all the way up
just to see he doesn't see yeah that's
fun
[ __ ] though yeah i don't think i've ever
done it on purpose i feel like i'm
feeling a little mini skirt
i feel like it i feel like it happened i
get
up how did they recover from that
there's no way they snapped back into
place after rocking that i did i got my
good fellas
a good good fellow
okay god fellow
whatever my underwear is how would i you
looked at me like i was going to confirm
the brand of your underoos we talked
about it the ones i get from target
who's the brand oh yeah it used to be
massimo and i think it's goodfellow or
something
long fellow deeds
um
i am very very sticky i am very very
sneaky uh this one's crazy i don't know
if we talked about it yet i remember
reading it this was from kristin ever
wait at the bottom of a water slide at a
hotel for the day so you can use your
goggles to find the change that fell out
of everybody's pocket what the [ __ ] yeah
how nuts is that what are you a 98 year
old man
after one of those things yeah that's
[ __ ] that's worse than a metal
detector that has to be a kid activity
that's not an adult i guess yeah how
would you have the money to get into a
hotel if you were doing that kind of
thing sure i mean no yeah no that's a as
a kid it's for sure as a kid but like as
a kid you're like oh let me go see what
[ __ ] you know coins i can pull up and
that's pretty smart to be hanging at the
bottom of the water slide yeah where it
all flushes out i'll give you that but
it's trashy it's very trashy um i've
never done that as a kid but i mean
we've this has been well documented in
the summers
you know you routinely went through
everybody's pockets in the closet every
coat pocket to find some kind of change
yeah yeah i remember one time i hit
[ __ ] pay dirt dude i mean it was like
it was like 80 bucks or something what
yeah the piece had like a couple which
the piece is real flustered when she's
checking out at the super fresh best so
it'll be like 20s and she'll [ __ ] in
the coat pocket or something you ever
get pinched
where's that money that was in my back
oh no this wasn't like july and it was a
coaching [ __ ] december wow so you
know no body no crime you know what i
mean that's fantastic yeah dude i
remember the one day i was in that like
i thought laffy taffy used to be
purchased with 80 beans i was looking
for like five bucks or something to go
like use a skateboard and like get your
head on straight just a [ __ ] you know
make right with the sharks
kick the vig down the road just to have
a couple uh you know be able to get some
snacks or something with them [ __ ]
deli while i'm [ __ ] hanging with the
boys
um maybe a slice of zod out there and
when you when you weren't flush for
snacks and everyone was grubbing that
was a tough look yeah we were always
real good though cause at some point
every like take care of each other my
boy pat was constantly flush yeah
because he would live with his grandmom
was always around so she would always
break him off with like a dub wow like
here's a 20 and that's 20 as a 10 year
old forget it you know kidding me so
[ __ ] buy your own hotel i remember
the one time my mom was telling i was
sitting there with my mom and my boy pat
we were in college probably like just
turned 21 maybe even before 21 and i'm
like mom we were so like bro college
kids like home for like christmas pro or
something thanks whatever we were both
home for the weekend
and we weren't working i was like mom
give us give me some money so we can go
drinking and she's like i'm not just
giving you money she's like there's beer
here like drink here like i'm not giving
you
50 bucks so you guys can go drink it at
the [ __ ] pub all night okay so then
same thing with past parents like we're
not just [ __ ] giving you money you
guys have been they take the night off
or whatever
so then pat's grandmom sent him a text
hey patch you know i stopped by the
house you weren't there i left 80 bucks
for you on the counter pat we got 80
bucks let's go i was like you're going
to spend you're going to split the money
with kevin that your grandmother gave
you he's like hell yeah we are yeah
unless you're part of the solution shut
the [ __ ] up i got [ __ ] core bombs
ah man
that was always big
um all right this one
this is an abbreviated one this is from
jesse ever burn your eyebrows off
because if you are you're probably doing
something you shouldn't be doing 100
doing what not all the way off but i've
singed them yeah yeah lighting the
bernie oh okay something else yeah
crack pipe
um
the big thing especially when you had
lighters as a kid you'd burn your leg
you ever like burn your leg hair oh yeah
yeah that smells
oh man it's gross and then i i drove for
a laser hair removal service for a long
time and they would do it in like a
regular doctor's office and after eight
hours of [ __ ] cooking
italian ladies [ __ ] legs
in long island dude you'd walk in there
it would hit you like a [ __ ] two by
four and i'd say to the technician like
how the [ __ ] can you stay in here now
hey you get used to it ugh burning hair
nasty
tough look
um
the other big thing as a kid with a
lighter would be burn your sock and it
would [ __ ] ever do that and it would
like wrap around your foot it would just
burn all like the the very fine hairs
that you like fibers that you can't see
on your sock should we do it no
uh i have brand new socks i don't know
if it would work uh there's like a box
[Laughter]
like the olympic torch
um and like the head the fibers you
can't see and it would like a blue flame
would run around your foot and then go
out right away it's a good time it's a
fun time yeah
it's not too shabby it's about two
notches underneath the fun of lighting a
fart on fire letting a fart i've never
done it oh my buddy kramer used to do it
all the time classic classic really what
we're elaine and georgia showstopper
showstopper what age were we talking
here a couple weeks ago
i don't know [ __ ] seventh eighth
grade okay i wasn't sure if you're doing
it in high school like a ladies you know
it might have been
yikes
tough tough freak
i don't know where they left
uh all right this one's from joe your
mom ever play candy crush mine is hooked
ugh
the these old birds and the embarrassing
it's a they're addicted she plays
something i don't know what she does it
ain't candy crush but yeah they're
they're always doing something your
mom's still playing candy crush no not
mine he was saying my mom is hooked oh
man if he's still pushing that um yeah
it's a tough [ __ ] look it always made
me want candy though hard case i don't
think i've ever played candy crush
i've never been big on games in general
video games weren't my stees
last system i had was a playstation 2
and i got so mad that i broke it
and then that was the last one i got a
little bit of an anger issue real cool
kid
remember i broke my sister's laptop too
she was home from college why because i
was playing a game and i lost and i
[ __ ] took the screen and snapped it
really yeah i assume that caused some i
then
i then slid it under the couch and like
kind of put like a half a blanket over
it to try to be like oh someone stepped
on it or something did it work i don't
think so ah she was like what are you
like and this was like this was like an
ibm this was i mean she went to college
like
she's like a little bit younger than you
right it's crazy you're older than my
sister that's nuts
um
she uh
i guess she's 40 maybe um
she had like one of those big black like
you know it came with like the bat like
you know what i mean it was like you
were calling it an airstrike
the red ball the red those things were
great i'm real [ __ ] tactical with
that you were playing solitaire
i didn't get the waterfall i can't
[ __ ] beat this guy
that was great when the waterfall with
the cards would happen well you watch
that for a couple hours
[Music]
yeah i've never tried to play with real
cars yeah my dad taught me hey you need
like eight tables
[Laughter]
it's
like you're you need a picnic it's like
you're an architect [ __ ] rolling at
the plane rolling out the drawings
[ __ ] putting them here putting the
[ __ ] get out of here
holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that was always big like launching a
controller too was [ __ ] i don't i never
played i never had any of the wireless
we were never those psycho kids i always
thought those kids were that was stupid
what
yeah it's more anger i'm not like dude i
used to lose to my brother on purpose
because he would hit me with a
controller if i beat him oh yikes way to
keep it cool psychos
holy [ __ ]
let's get a sleepover together huh yeah
right
this guy's putting on first down no
wonder why you guys were homeschooled
you were probably kicked out
[ __ ] couple that would have done better
for the record it did not for the record
it did not this one from adam shout out
to adam shout out to him uh we might
have talked about this at one point ever
wiped nose grease on the top of your
beer to get rid of the foam 100 yeah i
remember when that was shown to me i was
like holy [ __ ] that's gross but it
worked it's more of like a function
especially when you're playing beer pong
and you gotta [ __ ] or you're playing
like a drinking game and you gotta like
you gotta kill the foam quick
throw that in there now
take that one step further uh-huh have
you ever witnessed your server do that
as they were bringing your drinks what
yeah you've seen that i've seen that
you've done that i have not done okay
were you were you sitting were you at
were you uh were you a patron or were
you also working i was a patron at a
restaurant and the bar was right in
front of us and i saw a server do that
to somebody's drink and then bring it
over to their table it wasn't our table
what the [ __ ] yeah i'll take the can
please
how's the canned hamburger [ __ ] that
that's [ __ ] up oh man i i was just
somewhere this was probably 15 years ago
sure yeah yeah i think
i think when they were still smoking in
the restaurant
because more than 15 years ago ah yeah
it was probably 15 years yeah yeah yeah
15
16 i was in college when they banned
that
that no more thank god more bernie's
inside i mean dude that was brutal i
remember like i remember
working at martell's on the upper east
side in like i don't know 2000 2001
and
small little restaurant and i'm
literally having a bernie at the bar
sure and then we'll just put it in the
ashtray and walk over you guys ready to
order
yeah that's another thing too of i think
uh
so two stories one
i have to stop eating at a uh
bodegas like ordering like a sandwich
and stuff you do i i did i just the one
in my neighborhood just the guys played
a little too fast and loose
um with the cleanliness yeah especially
going there late at night you know what
i mean if you get back from like a spot
or whatever and it's midnight you're
like i'll pop in and get a sandwich it's
like
did i ask for a chicken parm and they
[ __ ] just did like the cheese they
get like the chicken cutlet like the
breaded already they just got to deep
fry it then they [ __ ] you know i'm
listening they put it on the griddle the
sauce the cheese cover it up it's easy
peasy what's the problem guy so i'm
sitting there only guy in there
then guy comes in he's like let me get a
a chopped cheese or whatever
i think he takes the hamburger the raw
hamburgers and chops it up
and then like i'm like dude and i'm
sitting there watching if i didn't see
it i wouldn't have mattered but i saw
him i'm like dude don't just immediately
go scoop up my thing with that [ __ ]
with the wrong you can see the raw meat
on the [ __ ]
on the [ __ ] spatulas
and i'm like don't do it man and he just
goes over scoops it up right on the
[ __ ] bun i walked outside threw it in
the trash i said i can't do it
okay i just can't and also i don't have
the tools to be like don't make me a new
one yeah like i'm just like i just go
now i'm done eating there but now also
you walk in there and they're eating
like what can i get you buddy i'm like
what the [ __ ] i don't know what are you
having
what do you recommend
jesus yeah they got like white sauce on
their face i'm like nah dude i'm out i'm
done dude i can't do it my bodega i went
and i asked for an italian hero they
gave me a chicken pesto panini
yeah some of them just play by their own
rules they don't give a [ __ ] dude
but also i was at a
i was at a diner last week you know
writing some jokes having a [ __ ]
omelette killing some time
and uh i go hey can i get another diet
coke he comes over
he comes over i was like i had a diet
coke
sitting there right he comes over i go
okay i don't know the guy cookie goes
yeah sure and grabs it like this with
his finger in the [ __ ] cup well
that's what i was gonna go reef and i'm
like i watched him i'm like if he gets
me a new cup like if he's busting the
table like this that's one thing but if
he refills this cup that his [ __ ]
finger was just in
did he refill it yes did you drink the
lemon what kept the lemonade no [ __ ]
weight that's why i asked you do you
know anybody that drinks like this
oh
yeah i do that a lot i mean one thing if
you're doing it i get whatever
it's your dirt you know refill but like
if a [ __ ] refill should be a new
glass i'd rather pay for it i i'll yes
if if dude if you're tr give me a new
car i want the fresh ice i want the
fruit the guy last night well at the
diner in jersey hey can i get a dog
another diet coke and i have like this
much left in mine and he just stands at
the table and waits for me to chug it
i'm like
this what the [ __ ] just go get me a new
glass there's four people in this
restaurant you got the glasses yeah
oh [ __ ] that's good um nice meal though
it was pretty good
uh okay sorry just checking something
real quick um
let's see this one's from alexander
brand new patreon here first time
question have you or anyone in your
family ever kept a bb gun by the bed to
take care of the squirrels in the attic
jeez that's
that ain't that's never had squirrels in
the attic had skunks in the crawl space
that's close enough to squirrels in the
attic i feel
i had raccoons in the living room from
like 87 to 89 my house had a had a
pretty thick skunk smell i think we
might
smell yeah i didn't know it was
lingering we had to moth ball a lot
mothball take care of it yeah they were
right right under the the front front
thing oh yeah tough look damn not at the
house you're in now yeah
really we weren't going to war with the
bb gun though we did we had a groundhog
problem i couldn't shoot a squirrel
i shot a rabbit once and we felt so bad
about it we buried it had like a we had
like a full service sure luncheon
afterwards
proper rabbit burial i thought we felt
never never picked up a firearm again
yeah after that i think i've mentioned i
i had bb guns all growing up mainly
because i think my mom would have led me
and i told my dad and he was like okay
we're [ __ ] strapping this kid's going
to be rambo so i had a bunch of them and
i shot a bird one time and killed it and
immediately felt bad oh it was one of
those things of like oh let me see if i
can get close or scare him or what like
no intention of me thinking i was going
to hit him red rider bb gun oh is it
eagle what'd you hit yeah bald eagle
i told you it pulls right
uh killed one in the backyard tried to
hide it and then someone found it was
like what the [ __ ] is this what i don't
know how mom i think
um he tried to hide it yeah it felt so
bad what are you in the gambinos
no body no crime
i ripped its fingernails off
[Laughter]
no i put it in like a brown bag and
threw it in the trash
but my problem was there was just nosy
broad doing snooping there was no other
trash in the trash can oh right it was
like the outside trash
down there well i think she grabbed a
brown paper bag and there was a bird in
it i think she was like what the this is
clearly something that i would have been
in therapy what after that that's psycho
kid [ __ ] yeah she was like what hat and
i remember telling her i was like hey
listen i didn't think i was gonna hit it
what happened yeah yeah one thing led to
another we were arguing how to call the
wolf
yeah yeah yeah important thing is we got
to get our story straight yeah first
things first i was never here
the bird cops show up i learned a lot
about kippy's snapping laptops in half
going on murder sprees
fat little weird kids what these were
these were old times what are you
talking about you get strep throat every
year
this kid's a lemon
get to me jesus christ get the extended
warranty on this one folks you're gonna
need it looks like a leaking oil oh [ __ ]
i killed a bird
put it around paper bag
hey that's not nice i don't know how you
would get up there that quick dude i
mean you got to be a pretty quick draw
where to if you to
still wake up out of a dead sleep grab
the bb gun get the ladder out get up i
think it's maybe if you're wouldn't even
get the ladder out
an attic oh i'm assuming you're shooting
through the ceiling that's what i'm
taking
i don't know
or if it's like trying to wall bang this
girl
i don't know
listen it's not suppressing fire
what the [ __ ]
hey cover me
i'm going to the bathroom
so i can saving private chipmunk jesus
christ man
i don't think that's what he meant
i don't know yeah dude they're gonna
wind up with a bunch of [ __ ]
christmas decorations with holes in them
yeah how are you gonna you can't shoot
through a drywall well that doesn't
matter that doesn't make sense to get a
gun and then i'm saying it might be like
an open rafter type situation i don't
know that doesn't make sense to get a bb
gun so this guy's got squirrels in his
house that's that's what i'm doing
they're not in the attic they're in the
house yeah
they've taken the guest room
[Laughter]
he wakes up ones on top of him with a
gun like karen hill yeah
what are you doing karen
my boys at drexel had that squirrel
scratches just put down the gun
professor whiskers how are you going to
do me like this
you got me all wrong see
might be must be some kind of dead eye
to shoot a squirrel yeah well it could
be using buckshot too who knows you know
could be got a good spread on it
y'all have a bb growing up you know
12-gauge
this is [ __ ] anton segura oh another
another
uh
another question that we've gotten a
handful of times i don't have the name
on it but i'm recalling it now have you
uh
what do you know about or does anybody
have the uh salt guns
no they kill flies the bug assault the
bug assault do you know that you you've
mentioned it to me oh i have yes oh okay
yeah uh and you for the break glass
no it's just like it's like [ __ ]
buckshot but salt and it's supposed to
kill flies you keep it if you have flies
or like gnats or fruit flies or whatever
and if you see it on the wall you just
[ __ ]
and it you know it's
awesome yeah i tell you the interior
living room is like a soft pretzel yeah
it's all [ __ ] over there's like a
super pretzel toby order three of those
extra ammunition yeah and some goggles
i'm using himalayan
good stuff
shooting pink mist at you
[Laughter]
i use rock salt
yikes trashy garbagio my friend that was
the thing as a kid growing up in the
south you hear about some someone
getting shot in the ass with rock salt
rock salt was big the farmers would have
it if you were there was always lures
because like where we grew up it was a
lot of farmland when i was like very
young that all like you know that all
became
uh was developed developed
uh but there was always like yeah
they'll shoot you know they'll [ __ ]
come out if you're [ __ ] around in the
thing yeah they said that about the
cornfield behind our house yeah i think
they would i don't [ __ ] never made a
move he knew better yeah got the quick
draw on them
um all right let's see this one's from
thomas i believe it's from facebook do
you have more keychains than keys
not a keychain guy at all i was never at
one point i think i had the bottle
opener and that was probably high school
college that's all i ever had for a
while i just had two loose keys that i
would carry around for the two days on a
ring nah no ring didn't like it i don't
like the way it felt in my pocket it was
just two keys
that's like cat burglar [ __ ]
that's weird
i break it everyone step away from like
unrolling like the thing and having all
the slim jims in there i don't think i
wish i had one of those that's real cool
a little thing that goes in and you put
the other one in and you flick on it
no way they're all you're all just
lifting the pins yeah no way though yeah
i used to work at a locksmith no big
deal oh look at you you had a lot of
hey
what locksmith did you work at it was a
lock and vault cause you made keys yeah
really they've made these keys before
i've pinned blocks
where you take like a
you take like a lock like a you know
whatever just like the base of a lock
and then you like each pin has a
different like code or whatever and you
drop the pins to make it a unique key
okay yeah
you're the key maker i was the key
master really master of the i've always
wanted to use one of those things i
didn't know how to do that the guys that
i worked with could obviously oh you
couldn't work the key thing what do you
mean you're telling me you were dropping
pins but you couldn't make keys
no i no made keys i'm saying i couldn't
break a i couldn't [ __ ] use the
scalpel and the [ __ ] no no i meant i
meant the the key maker thing the thing
that looks like a sewing machine of
course i've made that i've made
thousands of keys really yeah yeah yeah
thousands wow that's pretty cool i'm a
pretty cool guy as a kid that was like
meeting an astronaut yeah that guy it's
probably some drunk but
it was me
big-headed [ __ ] 21 year old i don't
even think i was 20 yeah i was 20 years
old really yeah
and i remember that it was a safe
company and they got real [ __ ] pissed
because on youtube it went viral uh some
like thief like you know like lock
breaking guy
uh had a youtube channel where he would
just break into like all these like
safes and stuff and we had like this
unbreakable safe and he broke into it in
like four minutes on youtube really yeah
they were real pissed they got into the
zx400 that's pretty sweet yeah i've seen
those videos where the people know the
the different sequences to push
for soda machines and stuff like that
yeah i think that's all kind of fake no
no it is
do you know anything of that like each
one has a secret code yeah yeah yeah
yeah i've done it is that real it is but
you can what
they it won't dispense for a while you
could get it to dispense but they fixed
that [ __ ] real quick ah did they uh you
know what i'm still impressed by but you
can you can like open the menus and like
change [ __ ] and stuff so much for free
sodas
you know what i'm really impressed by uh
vending machine technology to the point
where they have them at the airports i
don't that's the only time i really use
a vending machine is at the airport
after we land or a hotel or a hotel but
hotels don't have it airports for other
places have a dessert i've been in the
i've been in this in a vending machine
i've been in this the the snack slash
ice room with you many late nights oh
yeah
big fan big fan of like some cheez-its
some pretzels something absorbed all the
booze rolling all the ipa's floating
around grabbing a screamer um cold gady
raid
uh but they uh
the the thing that zips up and meets it
in the middle that's like then instead
of dropping
oh that's like ai technology dude that
there's
dude there's one at [ __ ] there's one
at the what the baggage terminal of
every airport whenever we're waiting i
always get like a [ __ ] drink and that
thing i sit there in amazement of how
that thing works that's like from irobot
type [ __ ] yeah dog when that thing first
dropped there was a hack where if you
put your hand on the door that it's
supposed to slide through it'll slide
it'll hit it it'll think it didn't
dispense the soda it'll give you a
second soda for
free wow that's pretty good
t-bone he probably has slugs for the
subway too this guy hey you chicago kids
man you guys are you guys are out there
huh wild hey who wants a free barks huh
[Laughter]
running him and his boys on a friday
night yeah they'll get you huh six pack
of soda hey fellas
get you
uh
let's see this is a first time question
this is from mike we've talked about
this have you ever purchased food in
like a strip mall i like the pizza place
and then your buddies were eating at the
chicken place and you took the pizza to
the chicken plate like taking outside
food into a place trash i've never done
it i've had
buddies that done it and i can't do it
you're a dirt ball if you do it and then
don't give the [ __ ] server an
attitude well they're reading shut the
[ __ ] up yeah yeah it's like get the [ __ ]
out [ __ ] yeah that's that's no
[ __ ] bueno kids is the difference
outdoor food you can't do kid's
different situation but cleaning you
bring the crackers or something for them
clean that [ __ ] up under the [ __ ]
high chair yeah okay especially if
you're a 15 percenter
yeah
i'm not [ __ ] cleaning up [ __ ] egg
noodles and [ __ ] mushed up string
beans from your little kid
now if you order some chickie fingers
for him like a gentleman he don't finish
him i'll take care of that
so you can do 15 all day man i got here
yeah
it's a thin line though sure with eating
off kids plates ow they're real gross i
would never but they don't finish
anything
sure you know mm-hmm it's tough yeah i
don't even like you know if my nephews
and stuff like i'll if they drop the
nuggets real quick i'll snag one no i'll
tell you what those two i don't go near
them
but they net literally like whole
hamburgers
but you just know there's you know even
as gross design yeah it's all buggered
yeah booger forcefield
no i'm telling you i was just home last
weekend or whatever uh
i went home had like dinner at the house
on sunday with the old nieces nephews
brother sister the whole nine everybody
was there
and for the kids they came out with the
chicken nuggets like they put in like
one you know two boxes like the weavers
or whatever they came out and dropped
those things crispy brown dude uncle
uncle kev was all over that stuff we
were talking one from each plate
fantastic
all right let's wrap it up gang we love
you uh it's been a family episode we
will uh kill you guys for him uh just at
cameron comedy on all social media let's
get those numbers up follow are you
garbage follow uh on twitter also too uh
if you're a i guess
there's a discord for the patreon
members uh that there we just
established a new admin or something
they're trying to get that booming so
check out the discord if you're on the
patreon very nice and don't forget come
see us gotham comedy club gothic gotham
comedy club new york city november 9th
tickets it's gonna sell out we said that
about philly and guess what it sold the
[ __ ] out
it sold out do it we love you come see
us we love you bye